get out of your comfort zone
don't hire somebody that's to your left
and to your right because they look like
you they act like you they think like
you they're not going to
get you know bring in anything new than
what you know um so i would rather
brighten my um
community or sense of network um tap
into organizations um tap into
companies who can support you whether
you're looking for board members or even
investors welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to be joined by
sephie dena siri the ceo and founder of
women of middle east in north africa in
technology previously known as persian
women in tech she is an award-winning
serial entrepreneur with over 16 years
of experience in the tech industry and a
lifetime advocate for women diversity
and inclusion prior she was co-founder
and managing editor of the digital and
print los angeles magazine and later is
the vice president of women 2.0 with
over 250 000 members worldwide and
partnerships with many tech companies
and corporations which was acquired in
2016.
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you today
good thank you so much michael for
inviting me and having this conversation
i'm super excited to
talk to you more about my work and what
we're doing and also hopefully
learn from you as well i love this new
platform
thank you very very much i'm i'm really
honored that to have you know somebody
you know be willing to stay with me for
20 minutes but i know how busy you are
so i'm going to make really the most out
of these 20 minutes and
so
the ceo and founder of women of middle
east and north africa in technology i
previously was known as persian women in
tech
prior to that you were the co-founder
managing editor of a digital and of a
digital imprint los angeles magazine
former vice president of women 2.0 uh
numerous awards i'm not even going to
try and start listing them now but what
i really want to try and understand in
these in these next 20 minutes is a
little bit about your understanding of
the ecosystem specifically women in
technology and mina and and a little bit
you know the insights that you gained
from years of experience that i just
don't have so so sepi walk me through
some of the bigger milestones in your
career and how perhaps they've helped
shape your understanding of of the world
around us yeah absolutely i mean first
and foremost i would say i'm an
immigrant i'm a serial immigrant um you
know coming from iran my background is
iranian i'm persian and then moving
diego ford to germany living in germany
so different culture and then moving to
united states so that already can give
you a little bit of perspective of you
know learning different cultures um
learning um to live in a different world
you know every country has its own
way of living and and so forth so that
was very interesting for me and i think
these are milestones we
we learn a lot um our capacity of
understanding as the human connection is
also different when we are living in
different countries as well and learning
that um so i would say that um coming to
the u.s
landed down the street from
um you know apple and sun microsystem
which which is different you know um i
feel this is a privilege having had that
opportunity um growing up and being able
to you know back in the days
the internet was a little bit different
i still hear the aol sound of
connectivity which is completely
different today and um being able to
dream you know back then even you know
we had that opportunity and and here in
california that dream is uh getting
wider and wider as you um explore your
career path so for me going to uci
in southern california
i studied business and psychology again
connecting
how to
do business we still are not dealing
just with robots there is the human
connection involved
um you know my milestones i think
throughout my career has been
being able to have opportunities um
starting right out of college with
co-founding um a technology company that
revolutionized the way we see
content online today you see
um forbes fortune new york times etc
having now pay wall where you know
content can be available online to
anyone in the world we started something
similar to that long long time ago and
then selling that company and
moving back to silicon valley because i
was in southern california
and looking at
startups and how they were thriving and
working on so many different technology
whether it's cloud computing video games
and whatnot um so my milestone you
really is that i open myself into
different industries and opportunities
that um usually people especially from
my culture my parents had a heart attack
thinking about she's gonna become an
entrepreneur which is not super stable
and i would even say it wasn't sexy back
in the days too to be an entrepreneur
what it is today and
and so um opening yourself um to being
okay
um in the unknown i think those are some
of my milestones i would have to say
and
so the passion for
women in mina in technology where does
that come from um i mean i understand
your personal story has a huge impact on
that but now you're taking it to another
level now you're working on a community
with i believe more than 30 35 000 women
yeah um and different types of women
from different upbringing cultures and
whatnot um
my passion is
coming from a drive to see how the world
is going to look tomorrow
um and
um
how the
future innovators are going to be
engaging what are they building
and
women
are part of that i mean 50 of the
population is women
and as we move forward and these
incredibly smart women who are not even
having a voice today there is a lack of
um
their voices where look in cna and
entrepreneur anywhere um i don't see
them as much um i don't see them
highlighted and and
um
how can the next generation whether they
live in the mena region or in the us or
canada or europe even imagine who they
can be someday when these voices are not
elevated
and
generally speaking women's voices need
to be elevated but minority groups like
the mena communities
is where my passion lies because that's
my background that's where the region i
am from and
looking at right now numbers even if you
were going to go with data 68 to 70
of um college graduates with a stem
degree in the middle east are women one
out of three startups um either led or
started
are women in the middle east so when you
look at those numbers they are going to
be your innovators um and so we need to
highlight them so women around the world
get more inspired um
and we can give them a voice
and so how did how does that voice
actually come about through
through your programs um
many ways um first and foremost putting
them on stages for them to share their
stories their challenges um
contributing um
to
educating our next generation in our
current generation
again we also educate our community
through workshops
and programs that we curate with the
help of our community and leaders
i also truly believe that not just the
community needs to be engaged but also
stakeholders so we partner with many
companies around the world in order to
help them impact their communities
and engage with their communities hire
them
and understand who their employees are
and what their challenges are so through
these engagements and programs we're
able to bring some change and move the
needle forward and essentially um the
work is supposed to also create a world
where the workplace is equal um and
there's diversity
right and so
take me back you know throughout your
journey you've been in this space for
years and so you know let's go 30 000
feet in the air
what what how does this work so how you
know where do you think is the the
disparity coming from and and
where where you know where the low
hanging fruits to improve on that and
i'm already hearing you say that you
know representation and inspiration
through media and through you know
visual and and auditory that that's a
really big part of it but you know where
are we headed to the society and what
needs to what needs to happen to really
move the needle here interesting i just
recently actually wrote an article on
entrepreneur.com about this how
companies need to really take a look and
and see
um how they're building their culture
and how they're tackling diversity and
you know there is a few things to think
about uh we can't just put them on the
pedestal and just showcase them we have
seen now just in the u.s
2.3 million women have left the
workforce i think this was end of 2020
so in the past six months that number
has even widened and increased as well
so um
looking at what is the workplace how are
companies and how are leaders um
changing because
we know and at women of media and
technology we have seen the past six
years the lack of
engagement and impact companies are
creating for diversity for um women in
the workplace and now with the pandemic
that has even worsened um so what can uh
companies do or how can we change things
is just the most basic things equal pay
um you know we have seen the ugly of uh
yeah
and you know that's the most simple
thing equal pay for equal work i think
that's where we can start
and um other things is don't guess what
you can do for your employees um survey
them figure out what you know you don't
know who they are you are putting a
check box together saying okay i have
this group or this cultural group and
whatnot but you really don't know um who
they are and how they identify
unless you ask your employees um so you
know recognizing
people generally
is important i think that lack of
sense of belonging is also something
that we see and for women particularly
that's why they're leaving the workplace
right they they don't feel they belong
um
and so at our organization we work with
companies to help them
understand and identify those challenges
whether it's internally or
um through
talent acquisition and so forth as well
very very cool and you know so one of
the interesting things here that i'm
that i am thinking of you know you're
not just an advocate for this you're
leading almost a movement or an
organization that is really you know is
a thought leader you know you're
positioning yourself as somebody that
you know
people look up to even just in the
thought of what needs to happen to
improve
where does that where does that meet you
where does that impact you on a personal
level that you now have this added
responsibility of you know being a
thought leader in this in this really
important movement
um i think
you know this responsibility has been
with me
throughout growing up
i can tell you in high school i started
the first peer counseling group for our
entire region
so
and i had only you know been an
immigrant and had been in this country
for two years at that point so
it's maybe a personality trait where i
identify um challenges maybe it's an
entrepreneur
mindset where um i i identify things
that are missing or lacking and i would
like to contribute to and you know
impact is really important when i leave
this world one day or the world that we
are creating all together as individuals
is going to stay here even when we leave
and i want to make sure that i've
contributed to a part of improvements as
well
so you know i think that everybody in
the world really or at least the people
that we really care about here they
would agree that you know equal pay for
equal work makes a lot of sense
inclusion diversity yes people are you
know preaching this you know from the
biggest ceos of adventure biggest
venture capital
why isn't it why aren't things moving
faster why why why
um i think uh why
is something that leaders or um
companies need to come with that answer
themselves a lot of it really has to do
with financials it's the number game you
know we
um
we're still
some of us um who are leaders have not
opened our mind into
what really equality means when you
don't have the right decision makers in
a room
and when you look at the companies
fortune 100 to 500
90 of them are men so
they don't have
an
a viewer or um an insight into what
their company is on their day today
and um most of women who would have
answers or would come up with
suggestions or might you know question
things because that's what it is right
leaders are i have to question certain
things and
looking at improvement but when they all
look at the same
they're only focusing on the things
that's interest to them
and so they are not looking at all the
challenges when you don't have a diverse
leadership when when you only have those
minorities or underrepresented um
communities as at your entry level and
that's the truth that most companies i
mean most women are working at entry
level they don't get to management level
so how are they going to voice these
type of challenges and problems um and
so once you
open those seeds and once you and not
just one seed i know california for
example has a mandate now as a rule you
have to have as a public company one
female on your boards that's not going
to change anything that person is going
to be overpowered by all the 20 plus
other
board members or 10 plus board members
so
really if you want to make changes you
need to make
you know changes
really thinking about
um how is this going to impact
how is this going to
make changes in our company or in our
organization
or in our community because essentially
it's all hand in hand
right so as you know as i go about my
journey and my friends go about their
journeys
us as young entrepreneurs we're just
starting out and we have the added
benefit of you know choosing our first
board members and choosing our first
executives to join us in our journey and
we don't have to go and change a hundred
thousand person company top down we can
we can start from the roots what are
some you know very tangible things that
i can be thinking about as i go about my
journey to to be a part of to be a part
of the improvement and not part of the
problem
um get out of your comfort zone
don't hire somebody that's to your left
and to your right because they look like
you they act like you they think like
you they're not going to
get you know bring in anything new than
what you know um so i would rather
brighten my um
community or sense of network tap into
organizations
tap into
companies who can support you whether
you're looking for board members or even
investors i think
looking at who you choose as your
investors is going to have a large
impact on the growth of your company and
the culture of your company as well
investors aren't just writing checks um
they're opening their network to you
they're opening their connections to you
and they're going to make
suggestions that are going to be a
positive impact on your company and
startup
no that makes a lot of sense now
every day you wake up and you continue
doing what you're doing and you're
continuing to do it with a passion
where you know where where does that
come from this you know what what and
i'm asking you know as a young
entrepreneur i want to find that passion
i want to find this spark that i'll wake
up every day saying this is my life
mission right now yeah you know i get
this asked a lot michael um
i i would have to say is the impact that
i create um the emails we get the
messages that we get that we change
someone's life um
we
provide an opportunity
through our programs or our network to
someone to find a job to you know for
someone to get inspired to become a
software engineer or someone to get
inspired to start a company or innovate
something and connect them to an
investor and now their company is
thriving so when i look at the
impact our organization has on our
community on our women um is what
excites me and the passion that i have
to wake up either at 3am and have a
meeting with london or you know um
talking to people in the middle east
because at the end of the day
as i mentioned this early on um for me
is building a legacy for our community
is really important
i i love that essentia thank you so much
for coming i really appreciate it i have
a few more questions not about
women and men and technology and and
going back a little bit to your
childhood what really fascinated you as
a kid whether it's a subject in school
or a passion hobby
yeah you know actually what passionated
me uh or the fascination i had was for
space it's so far away
we don't know a lot about it we just
know that it exists and we can learn
about it
um and i was so fascinated to to know
and get to know more about space you
know how can people space travel and so
forth and you know that fascination for
me that you can't always know everything
but you can have that inspiration for it
translated into everything else that
i've done as well you don't know what's
tomorrow but you know you want to know
or create that tomorrow
very cool and
who who has been a source of inspiration
for you along your journey specifically
who who inspires you in the work that
you're doing today yeah
um many people i i have never looked at
just one person or one ceo or i think
just normal people sometimes my parents
inspire me i've seen how much resilience
they have had to you know start from
zero two times um with children
you know three children exact and and
coming into countries where they didn't
know anything and i have to thank them
for who i am today and the success that
i have today i have to
um you know acknowledge it and so
and other people i see you know malala
and the resilience she had through her
experience and what she took out and the
strengths she had to move forward and
the movement she has created and
continues to be her own person
um so people like that i i truly don't
think only ceos and and so forth who are
sitting high up are the source of
informa uh inspiration for us as
individuals i think we look at someone
and the journey they have taken and that
can inspire us
as one
very very cool and what are the three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
um
i have a lot of resilient i don't
believe in no
there is a maybe and let's see later
um i'm very consistent with that so
resilience is one um
i
i believe that i'm also very passionate
about anything that i do and just about
life i think that's really important
that you have to love life to continue
and continue your work and and have that
passion
the last one
describe um
i think happy
i'm just a happy person
to describe myself but
it's because
i don't know i mean you have to be i
don't know i'm very happy and i think
those things combination um
brings the personality that i've needed
throughout the years of being who i am
or do the work that i needed to do
so those would be the combination of who
i am
you ask my friends they might tell you
the difference
thank you so so much this was wonderful
and thank you for coming on i i really
loved it thank you for teaching me so
much and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you michael have a
fantastic day talk to you soon